[Musica]
sì sboccia comino le tue andare via dai
miei cazzo di video che cazzo ci fai qui
da tre giorni porca [ __ ] della tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti che sono vivo io
sono fra vj oggi i ragazzi siamo sue
primis ma voglio fare una sfida che
avevo in mente di fare da un po io e
questo comito questa sfida che volevo
fare da un po posso farla soltanto se
sono con qualcuno in questo caso
giovanni che praticamente consiste nel
fare è giocare a the peawees bendato
bendato significa che faccio i livelli
ma non vedo che cosa sto facendo io ho
bisogno appunto di qualcuno che mi dica
che cazzo sto facendo cioè cosa fare più
che altro ci sei non aveva una benda ma
avevo questo che permette scende giù
questa cosa dell'ermo che io sono poco
acculturata non so come si chiama scende
giù la visiera dell'elmo e non vedo più
un cazzo quindi giovanni premio giorgio
vanni giorgio vanni mi deve dire che
cazzo devo fare perché sennò meglio lei
ora grazie partiamo con un'accusa facile
mai superbotto non sa bene dove il tema
è molto pratico adesso vado forte io no
dai ho vinto sei capace ad andarvi dire
ma come modesti impennare tu sei intendo
faccio lo faccio sono carico morte parte
così me non meno impennato ero ragazzo
io è impennato troppo sei andato in
testa coda arrivate troppo troppo troppo
troppo remoto da affanculo la gente il
mio figlio
non vedo un cazzo che cosa fare allora
secondo te un consiglio beh che cazzo di
consiglio e dimmi qualcosa di mi.fi cosa
capisco io da un bene ed io mi ha
veramente sono facevo dato era meglio
dammi la mano seria ma impegnati se ti
dico troppo impegnati meno ma non
smettere di impennare fenomeno che ha un
ritmo di volante va bene questo andato
lascia un attimo così così così bravo
dopo windows
poi sul serio senza che non c'è più un
cazzo se così a metà la cosa e persona
gamba bene una vita per fare questo
fantasy questa ragazzi era una prova da
questo momento in poi io non tirerò mai
più sulla visiera quindi coprob 66 se
sia normale rilasciati ti dico quando
prendere e non ti sei lasciato che si e
gambe le braccia ragazzi funziona questa
cosa vedo la z ok non è stato fatto ma
dove sono ha esaltato il segue i sei
andato dall'altra parte facciamo una
cosa seria non ti dico io quando tener
va indietro normalmente indietro
chiariti viene però va bene sei persone
tra torca è bravo ora lascia bravo
veramente capito leccese sono emozionati
e in itinere mantiene ti tieni ti senti
lasciati cazzo per un pelo e che se la
posizione giusta se apparse in faccia
anche perfetto pgt enke lascia grande
c'è mai sono un braccio tieniti finito a
casa l'unico grosso che artistico quando
lasciarono subito lascia subito è no eh
sì fai ancora un giro fai ancora gb
lascia subito quando me lo dice
spetta vai la chance non tieni bravo
proprio perfetto nasce lasciare ai per
entrambe le braccia e allora potresti
ancora vincere aspetta aspetta russi sa
adesso se in un cannone ti sta buttando
in un canale potresti vincere ci farebbe
dio non so dove vado ti prego 21 via
sì se il traguardo
se è facile abbraccia bella ciao bella
fratello mia città lorca la lanca
seccato il cingoli perciò ayane
non ci credo mai vai cavi a livello
soprattutto a carico sono veramente
umore san saba dono tutto euforico porca
eva vai cambia media non ci credo
funziona harbour and medium così è
troppo difficile
io gli apporti giardino fare se vedo
velocissimo ormai impegno qualsiasi
permesso l'impennata ragazzi quale
bisogna stai facendo
ma quanti sono quanto di più basta già
farlo finire già bravo è stato il
livello difficile ottenuto un tasto
sword cruda e vaino sua troppo allora
partito subito si sono già peccato
nessuno bravo due ne beccati c'è il
bambino sotto secondi non so però hai
preso dietro ad esso sono dietro no
troppo alto bravo bravo e preso il
bambino
bravo grazie grazie a tutti da zte è la
ricordate la [ __ ] canto c'è una tipa
convoglio tutte le lei voglio tutte le
lei disse fuori casa della tipa non
posso non posso perché non voglio
guardare finché rovescia puntata puoi
essere tipo vin diesel riddick che non
vede un cazzo ragazzi voi non avete idea
di come cazzo fa caldo sotto un cappello
di lana in pieno agosto non ne avete
idea long spike for love fiore lungo
indovina quanto è lungo e come lungo
allora vai avanti
[Musica]
diventeremo più lento che hanno sono
abbiano sono piano ok basta
potresti potrebbe potrebbe vincere
potrebbe vincere ricchi premi sapere
l'italiano ma sai che ti può in alcuni è
più vista ho fatto meno livello sono
uscito a fare meno livelli che adesso
incredibile vai cambiava che sul carico
i fori ragazzi 100.000 line e dovete
cliccare il tasto like senza guardare
perché se non vale 90 per cento imposti
con impossible cycle il prossimo sono
carichi se ne sono saltare non c'è
niente su una mina
bravo nei tre giorni ma ora ce n'era una
che ove sei morto non ho notato dimmi
cos'è successo
e ti sei schianto avvenuto degli
spuntoni c'è perché c'è la mina su un
palo e questo ne contano soprattutto
valide visti andarci in m
porca eva l'ho sentito cena gesù che mi
sussurrava ho sentito una cosa da non
sentire cosa il civate campione vero un
po a me da rivedere ti prego voglio
rivederla fabio e vabbè matrix fate col
tipo di maestri ninja che mettono le
bende non vedono un cazzo e scrivano
fantastico 20 la cera togli la cera
jonas quale la cosa strana è che lo
riguardano questo video e non ho visto
né niente tipo rock swing non sapevo
neanche quando mi dicevi grappa di non
capire a che cosa mi stesse gradino poi
vedrò ho fatto dei livelli che non ho
neanche visto bellissimo steelhead e
coin dai non è difficile sono solo
quattro ce la faccio a fare il caso sono
innanzitutto la bici perché no no no
stai fermo sa cosa ho una bici cosa sei
colpo si è spaccato esattamente novità
aspettaci l'ultimo arpione che si è
incastrato con l'ultimo al fiore
sentiamo [ __ ] e ti alzi ce la puoi
fare non c'è più niente
adesso la sfera eletto al consiglio
perfetto giovani valle bravo sei avanti
alla moneta torna in di vaio poi al tema
dhofar riello bravo se grazie grazie a
tutti grazie mille sono la persona
fortissimo che caldo faggio fa
caldissimo just do it fa caldissimo so
cosa sia già due basta un padre vai sono
padre vado
vai più forte più forte se vado forte
vado a morto malissimo [ __ ] vi
facciamo noi penserai nel culo se
vengono 6 mentre nel culo madonna e
schivato il traguardo si è andato oltre
ma dovrebbero davvero cazzo ci hai fatto
e non ho capito neanche cosa stavo
schivando c'è ti rendi conto di non so
che cosa ho giocato come se guardasse
questo video occhi chiusi io sento solo
lui che dice vai vai vai vai presento
tartara quando vince non capisco un
cazzo di quello che succede però va bene
esci da questa cosa faccio io esco io
fermo fosse andato un altro sito
no no stai avendo cazzo in florida gazin
glory si chiama è più il sa che quello è
come veramente mai tra tutti i giochi
nella vita avevo ragazza il glory o
incredibile anche quella che sarebbe più
easy incredible truisi c'è apposta per
terra non c'è scritto boltro per fa
vigeva in quanto ci sono quattro cose ma
dov'è la vittoria è l'ultimo quindi
della via è lontana forme mediamente ho
vinto ai bloccato la morte bene ho vinto
come si aspetta lasciati lasciati andare
la vita va bene ti faccio perché sono
forte le so niente non ho vinto
riprendendo la chiave ma che avesse
preso insieme ma allora cagando
stoviglierie scotti chiusi cambia cambia
anche queste per il bere per bambocci wi
fi combattere con i pon rai che con base
ai pronto sono forte io vado ciao justin
bieber dove sono stata incompleta
grazie justin bieber non è stato il
padre john zhao padre di justin
grazie justin bieber che caso di ok ok
piano 6 tornando indietro
justify mozzato già strimenti s'è preso
insomma cetera il tu devi saltare di
saltare davanti attenti bravo non sei
vivo se c'è una spada nel collo ma se
incredibilmente vivo adesso si guarda
con guarda l'opera d'arte bella che
cazzo è successo qua hai una spada nel
collegio avuto con la scuola nel suo
collo e l'età colpito con un'ascia che
aveva e wish e su quello che ha colpito
entrambi con la stessa che gioco del
cazzo va bene dai fammi fare l'ultimo
fatto bene e basta che sono poco carico
l'ultima deve essere 99 per questo
questo non impossibile ma che ci sono i
camion i camion quelli grossi più grossi
santo forte ho vinto moltissimo
terminato imparato album io mio
mischiano dare tanto a destra che ci
puoi fare ciò che vuoi fare se vuoi fare
sia pulito consentito sentito rumore non
sai come vintage da fatelo rivedere
perdere possibile minimo sforzo
forse è morto e rimarca che non si sa
come fucina dei ragazzi basta i ceppi
catalogare barbassa perché ho caldo
veramente calvo in voi no non c'è acqua
e non sapete con voi non sapete cosa
significa avere caldo in questo ma tanto
foto forte va bè ragazzi io che un
colloquio episodio direi che basta
perché anche se non so che cosa ci sta
anzi fatemi vedere
[Musica]
questo è un po che è un po che non è un
pokémon ho perso i capelli prima ci
avevo tanti adesso non meno dei ragazzi
ho perso i capelli e unipi a ogni mi
piace un cappello in più quei ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto io vi
ringrazio per averlo visto un mi piace
solo per cui almeno per il caldo se
volete un navigatore come me non c'è
poco suicidate vi ringrazio giorgio per
avermi fatto da occhi in questo video
spero che tu non debba mai farmi da penn
e spero che viene serve 100 ragazzi cosa
mi è piaciuto questo argomento è un mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e come
vi dotata la descrizione sono già
riusciti scritte ce la fai prende il
comando favore grazie io ti ammazzo
riprende un telecomando una cosa devi
fare
voi non sapete dove lo tiene un altro
segreto è perché questo è il telecomando
mio che quello della storia è nascosto è
ovvio perché questo ha un valore 10 euro
su ebay sono stati fischiati ci vediamo
adesso 717 di sky ci vediamo al prossimo
video